[موسيقى]
هذا هو ملعب الوجنيكي التاريخي اشهر ملاعب
روسيا والقاره العجوز يدخل مرحله الثبات
الشتوي في وقت تتعلق فيه عيونه عشاق
المستديره بملاعب قطر وبطولتي كاس العالم
وعلى بعد بضعتك كيلومترات يبدو المشهد
مختلفا كليا في شوارع المدينه حيث لا يمكن
للمرء تصديقه ان كره القدم هي اللعبه
الشعبيه الاولى في بلاد الثلج
الروسي الذين كانوا البارحه يرحبون على
ارضهم بضيوف النسخه الماضيه يعرفون جيدا
لذه اجواء كره القدم وما تحمله من اثاره
لكن تعاملهم مع نس مشحون بالخيبه والغيره
والحسد خاصه مع نينهم البطاقه الحمراء من
التصفيات المؤهله للمونديال بسبب عقوبات
الفيفا
نابرت كستراليا
باعتبار ان المونديال يجري في ارض عربيه
قلبنا كان مع الاخضر السعودي والان مع
المغرب وبالطبع مع حليفنا صربيا
كاس العالم عندما تلعب روسيا فقط اما الان
فلا اهتم
[موسيقى]
صراع موسكو مع الغرب ذهب بالاتحاد الروسي
لكره القدم للبحث عن تحويل عضويه البلاد
الى الاتحاد الاسيوي علما ان لدى موسكو
حتى الان فرصه محتمله للمشاركه في تصفيات
اليورو القادمه حسب روايهتهم عبد الجواد
الرشد العربيه